لا يكاد يمر يوم على ابناء الضفه الغربيه
دون مشهد كهذا بلده يعبد تشيع احد ابنائها
الفتى عمر ابو بكر البالغ من العمر 16
عاما الذي منعت قوات الاحتلال فرق الاسعاف
من الوصول اليه بعد اصابته بالصدر برصاص
قوات الاحتلال اثناء اقتحامها لهذه البلده
الاقتحام ادى الى اصابه شابين اخرين هذه
الممارسات احدثت غضبا كبيرا لدى ابناء هذه
البلده التي خرجت عن بكره ابيها لوداع
نجلها تماما كما حدث مع عدد من المحافظات
والمخيمات والمدن الفلسطينيه في اقتحامات
موسعه تقوم بها قوات الاحتلال في مختلف
المحافظات في الضفه الغربيه اقتحامات تؤدي
بشكل دائم الى اصابات وشهداء وعدد كبير من
المعتقلين في اطار تصعيد واضح تشهده الضفه
الغربيه
حسن مسعود الجزيره يعبد جنوب غربيه جنين